- Salut Romain, ça va ?
- Non, je crois que je vais avoir l'appendicite...
- Ah merde, t'as mal au ventre ?
- Non, non non
- T'as de la fièvre, t'as envie de vomir ?
- Non
- Bah t'as quoi exactement ?
- J'ai avalé mon chewing-gum sans faire exprès
- Ah ouais, ouais d'accord
[générique]
L'appendicite vous connaissez ?
Même si ça se s'opère beaucoup moins qu'avant
je suis sûr que vous connaissez et je suis sûr que vous avez entendu dire que si on avale ce chewing gum
on risque de l'avoir, l'appendicite, mais est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Et bah ça, ça c'est...
[Jingle]
Alors on va commencer par le début
l'appendice c'est un petit tuyau en cul de sac de quelques centimètres de long, de quelques millimètres de diamètre qui est accroché à la première
partie du colon qu'on appelle le caecum et qui se trouve là juste en bas à droite
c'est une structure vestigiale, c'est à dire le vestige d'un organe dont l'utilité chez les êtres humains a
diminué au fur et à mesure de l'évolution
alors attention on sait quand même qu'il produit des anticorps et que c'est une sorte de
réservoir à flore intestinale de secours donc, il n'est pas complètement
inutile mais il est pas du tout indispensable non plus on vit très bien sans. Bon et alors l'appendicite
la plupart du temps ce qui se passe c'est que le petit tuyau il se bouche et comme c'est un cul de sac
les bactéries se développent à l'intérieur, et ça s'enflamme, ça s'infecte, ça gonfle, ça fait mal, ça donne de la fièvre etc
et c'est considéré comme une urgence parce qu'il faut retirer l'appendice avant que ça s'aggrave. Et donc qu'est-ce qu'il le bouche ce petit machin ?
et bah en général ce qu'il bouche c'est du caca
faut dire qu'il a pas mal dans le secteur dans certains cas ça peut aussi être des résidus
d'alimentation genre des pépins de fruits, ça peut aussi être un parasite genre un ver mais tout ça c'est très rare. Et donc ce qu'on raconte
c'est que si on avale ses chewing gum ils peuvent faire un bouchon et provoquer une appendicite. Et bah c'est faux
pour comprendre pourquoi c'est faux il faut savoir ce que deviennent les chewing gum quand on les avale
les chewing gum ça fait partie des matières non digestibles
c'est à dire que les sucres de l'estomac n'arrivent pas à les dissoudre du coup ils restent beaucoup plus longtemps dans l'estomac
et ils mettent beaucoup plus de temps à faire tout le trajet le long du tube digestif, mais pas plusieurs années hein
juste quelques heures de plus que d'habitude. Donc les chewing gum comme les autres matières non digestibles ils restent plus longtemps dans le tube digestif
mais ils finissent par resortir
juste ils ressortent tels quels
sans boucher l'appendice. Attention ça veut pas dire que c'est complètement impossible ça veut juste dire que c'est pas une cause
d'appendicite connue. On n'a pas retrouvé de chewing gum dans les appendices des gens qu'on a opéré. Ou tant qu'on y est ça reste pas
sept ans dans l'estomac comme on peut l'entendre dire et ça ne colle pas les parois non plus
"You made me swallow my gum !"
Par contre ce qui a été décrit par des médecins c'est des cas d'occlusion intestinale
chez des enfants chez qui on a retrouvé des masses de chewing gum bloqués dans le rectum, y'en a même un qui parle de masse
multicolores
C'est joli mais ça bouche le rectum... Après bon faut savoir que les enfants en question ils avalaient 5 à 7 chewing gum
tous les jours donc, bon  ça reste très rare mais ça existe c'est possible. Le mieux dans le doute c'est quand même ne pas les avaler
mais bon si vous en avalez un de temps en temps y'a pas de souci. Et pour finir sur une note positive
sachez que certaines études suggèrent que le fait de mâcher du chewing-gum après une opération cela pourrait accélérer le retour du transit intestinal
faut juste mâcher pas avaler
globalement mâchouiller si vous voulez mais n'avalez pas
de chewing-gum. Voila DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si vous vous posez d'autres questions de ce genre
envoyez les moi à questiondtc@gmail.com, on se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien :)
[Musique]